on y revient dr weiss la coved 19 est
beaucoup plus mortel comme maladie que
la grippe saisonnière alors absolument
aucun doute là dessus
on a beaucoup plus de décès une chose
qu'il faut dire au québec on est on a
des statistiques qui sont très bien
faits sont fiables
on a fait des ajustements ici et là mais
je peux vous dire que à l'échelle
mondiale dont les certainement à des
endroits où l'on compte le mieux ce
genre de statistiques là donc quand on
vous dit qu'on attend des signes journée
étant déçus l'autre journée c'est vrai
c'est très précis et on n'a jamais ça
avec la grippe on n'a jamais cette
situation là avec l'amérique
et c'est vrai aussi dans d'autres pays
occidentaux dans d'autres pays en
amérique en amérique du nord
c'est vrai donc on sait qu'actuellement
le taux de mortalité de lakovic 19 aussi
on va dire autour de 1 1%
et c'est vrai que 1 % dans une
population ou pour quasiment toute la
population peut être affecté c'est quand
même énorme
on voit jamais ça avec la grille l'autre
chose qu'il faut faire attention c'est
les chiffres de mortalité par rapport
aux hépatites à la tuberculose etc
ce sont des extrapolations à l'échelle
planétaire se sont pas des chiffres qui
sont fiables du tout est ce qu'on ne
voit pas par contre avec l'aco
villeneuve s'est beaucoup de mortalité
qui n'est pas répertorié dans beaucoup
de pays où les choses ne sont pas faites
comme au canada dont vous avez les pays
d'afrique et des pays en amérique du sud
en amérique centrale
il ya même des pays ou alors de façon
peut être volontaire le nom de man n'est
pas répertorié adéquatement
donc à mon sens on sous estime la
mortalité réel de lakovic 19
surtout ne se prend pas du thé bête je
parle pas d'eux des pays d'europe de
l'amérique du nord ou de certains pays
même d'asie mais qu'il ya des endroits
dans le monde où pour toutes sortes de
raisons c'est très sous-estimées et on
surestime des fois la mortalité qui peut
être associé à léa aux hépatites au vih
un autre état bon ben je vous arrête là
parce qu'on voit le tableau c'est
extrêmement intéressant ce que vous
dites oh on a un pic quotidien de la
coved 19 à semelle 10 par jour donc là
c'est bien au delà de l'épaté de la
tuberculose du sida de la malaria mon
yann 2730 ce que vous nous dites dr
weiss et que la moyenne de 2730 et doit
être beaucoup plus élevé que ça compte
tenu du fait que tous ne sont pas nos
pas le comptage au québec là autrement
dit il ya des gens en afrique en prêt au
brésil on l'a vu même aux états unis
ailleurs on ne compte pas avec autant de
précision les morts donc la coved 19 du
plus que les chiffres officiels tout à
fait prenez les grands pays très peuplés
de la planète on s'est probablement que
les chiffres en chine ne sont pas
fiables du tout pensé en inde on ne
répertorie pas tous les décès il ya 1.3
milliard d'habitants les pays très
peuplés comme l'indonésie le brésil
pakistan le bangladesh
ce sont des pays qui ont certainement
des cas de coville
d'ailleurs vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
l'om s1 répertorié que setting des
journées où on enregistré le plus de
nouveaux cas depuis le début de la
pandémie à l'échelle planétaire
et donc ces pays là ne répertorie pas
tous les décès de la même façon qu on le
fait dans d'autres zones géographiques
donc on sous estime leur nombre de cas
est encore une fois tant pour qu'on
passe à autre chose pendant tendance à
surestimer les autres choses
ben justement alors je veux revoir le
tableau vous êtes on sous estime ce qui
est à droite là le 2730 qu'on va revoir
on le sous-estiment et on surestime
l'hépatite tuberculose vih sida malaria
de telle sorte que la coved 19 serait la
maladie infectieuse la plus meurtrière
sur la planète actuellement fort
probablement et surtout en occident vous
savez des gens qui meurent de
tuberculose au canada c'est quasiment
zéro des gens qui meurent aujourd'hui de
malaria c'est exceptionnel c'est
évidemment des malaria a porté de retour
de voyage et des gens qui vont mourir de
maladies comme le vih était moi ça fait
plus de 25 ans que je pratique en
maladies infectieuses j'en ai vu des
veilleurs j'ai vécu aussi comme récitant
le début du vih et le début du sida ses
envies dans une autre époque
il ya quasiment plus personne qui meurt
du vih en occident de nos jours non et
par rapport aux autres grandes maladies
par rapport au cancer ou de maladies
cardiaques l'aco vide se classe
malheureusement assez haut dans le
classement aussi lassitude c'est pas
pour rien autrement dit que les pays les
dirigeants ont pris peur eurent décidé
de tout geler la sec avait un risque
énorme de mort tout vous avez tout à
fait raison et c'est pour ça qu'on n'a
pas pris une décision comme ça la légère
maintenant il faut toujours savoir
qu'aujourd'hui avec les médias sociaux
toute l'information la façon dont les
choses sont véhiculés à travers la
planète comment se fait-il qu'on est
capable d'aller fief certainement des
gens qui ont un intérêt à diffuser cette
fausse information
et c'est probablement pour ça que toutes
les théories de complots et c'est qu'on
exagère pour surestime les chansons
sorties vous savez on a eu la même
histoire avec le h1n1 en 2009
je dois vous couper parce qu'on a pu le
temps l'émission va se terminer mes
docteurs
c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime pour vous
apprécié parce qu'on remet les choses en
perspective
c'est longtemps je voulais faire ça on
va leur faire et piso dyckmans important
de rappeler les bases de cette crise
merci au revoir le désire on saurait